aujourd'hui on a marqué l'histoire
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de québécois
qui ont mille côté un débord qui nous a
divisés de 50 ans aujourd'hui beaucoup
de québécois qui ont fait la
démonstration que c'est possible de
faire travailler ensemble des
adversaires diar pour travailler pour le
québec de demain
enfin
donc on ne réussit à rassembler et c'est
dans cet esprit de rassemblement que
j'ai l'intention de gouverner pour tous
les québécois
tous les québécois j'y vais tous les ans
toutes les femmes de bonne volonté à
joindre à nous à mettre l'épaule à la
roue pour faire plus pour faire mieux
pour tous les québécois
aujourd'hui les québécois ont choisi
l'espoir l'espoir d'un gouvernement
portant d'un changement positif et mon
équipe on a vu plusieurs le mât
merveilleuses écrire avec vous jean
louis en faisant plaisir
[Musique]
je vous garantis qu'on vote tout donner
tout donner ce qu'on a
pour répondre à cet espoir et on va se
faire d'abord pour les familles pour les
enfants non refaire aussi pour nos aînés
qui ont bâti le québec moderne
on va le faire aussi pour nos régions
donc on veut se donner un gouvernement
efficace humain un gouvernement quel
camp la bonne place mais les deux pieds
sur terre et vous savez on a des défis
immenses devant nous mais on est
capables nous les québécois de relever
ces défis ne oui on est capable
oui on est capable
cha cha québécois québécois je suis
vraiment honoré de la confiance que vous
m'avez accordée aujourd'hui je vous ai
déjà dit que pour moi la principale
qualité d'un premier ministre cdh a mis
les québécois j'oublierai jamais jamais
à
là
voudrais commencer par remercier les
électeurs de l'assomption qui m'ont
renouvelé leur confiance
je voudrais aussi féliciter je n'ai vu
c'est ça ça me fait de la peine
celles et ceux qui sont présentés qui
ont pas toujours gagner merci merci pour
votre confiance et toutes les personnes
qui ont le courage de se présenter
mérite le respect des québécois et j'ai
parlé un peu plus tôt à monsieur
couillard monsieur lisez mal en masse et
les a félicités pour leur campagne et je
veux rappeler à tout le monde au québec
que même son nez des adversaires on
n'est pas des ennemis
il ya beaucoup plus de choses qu'on
partage quelque chose qui nous divisent
sort jamais n'oubliez
foi des candidats candidate la compag a
nié je vous lève mon chapeau
vous avez fait honneur à la démocratie
puis on a à notre parti merci merci
merci
on peut féliciter les 125 élus de toutes
les formations politiques
bien sûr en particulier la nouvelle
équipe de députés de l'acca vous dis
bienvenue dans l'équipe chat
peu j'en ai vu plusieurs amendements
tantôt l'eau mais je veux aussi dire
merci à tous les bénévoles de la 4 roues
y avez cru dans certains cas depuis
longtemps
puis vous avez tout donné en particulier
dans les dernières semaines
je veux vous dire un gros merci merci
aux bénévoles
veut dire un merci spécial à ma famille
qui m'ont soutenu mais 2 go by isabelle
un particulier
[Applaudissements]
et
au delà de sefyu ou citoyens au cours de
cette campagne vous avez été exposé à
des débats très chaud mais cette
élection est terminée elle commençons
donc à travailler ensemble pour le
bénéfice de tous les québécois et les
québécoises
let's work bérard lyon ensemble afin de
faire du québec une province plus fort
au sein du canada et je veux vous
assurer que mon gouvernement sera votre
[Musique]
les amis ce soit les québécois ont fait
l'histoire et on fait confiance à un
nouveau parti si pour relancer le québec
on a maintenant une grande
responsabilité mais je suis certain
qu'avec mon équipe avec l'aide de tous
ceux et toutes celles à qui je tends la
main
ce soir on va bâtir un québec plus fort
un québec plus fier
[Applaudissements]
je termine je termine en vous disant ce
soir au bord célébrer la victoire
après on va aller se reposer quelques
heures mais dès demain dès demain on va
se retrousser les manches et on va
travailler pour faire plus pour faire
mieux pour tous les québécois
merci
[Applaudissements]